welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for the matrix resurrections
this fourth film ingeniously restages
moments from the past trilogy with new
actors doing their best impressions as i
no joke spent my teenage years doing in
front of a webcam which i pray every
night that the architect wasn't watching
those i am gonna break down the visual
details no one else seems to be talking
about from this trailer and do my best
to put it all in context and before we
begin keep an eye on the red versus blue
imagery throughout this trailer and pay
special attention to the music because
it's actually rage against the machines
wake up which you'll remember ending the
1999 matrix film except now it's an
orchestral version by sebastian boom
[Music]
one of many ways this movie is as a
whole a meta cover of what came before
so let us red pill into this
we can't see it
but we're all trapped inside these
strange repeating loops
billions of so swat agents swarm in to
arrest trinity as we saw in the prologue
of the 1999 film but this is a restaged
version of it because the wall that
trinity faces is different this one has
two glass panes with cracks mirroring
the two tears in the projector screen
later on mirrors are obviously
significant symbolically in this film
and practically their gateways through
the looking glass keeping up the alice
in wonderland motif also this is not
carrianne moss the recent deja vu
trailer revealed this is actually
actress ellen holman so this is an
example of the loops that morpheus is
talking about in this trailer in this
seventh iteration of the matrix after
neo reached that truce with the machines
to rid them of the agent smith virus neo
and trinity have apparently been
restored and reinserted into a new
simulated world in which the matrix
films are fictional pop culture to these
people so that neo would interpret his
dream memories as just his life
reflecting the art he consumes and
therefore not question his reality and
preventing the humans from regaining
their greatest weapon against machines
in this cold war in fact the 1999
opening that we see in this movie may
actually just be a recast and re-shot
version of those events from the first
film in a new movie that these
characters watch because the matrix
resurrections appears to be
deconstructing the way our hollywood and
our world reboots franchises as
nostalgia machines so that we're never
really experiencing anything new or real
just really repackaged archetypes that
we've seen hundreds of times neo meets
trinity in the simulate coffee shop as
she turns back to look at him and he
flashes back the shot of her from the
matrix reloaded the moment she left him
with his zion worshipers except here the
shot is mirrored from the reloaded shot
mirrors and notice that she follows a
kid with a blue hat a blue shirt blue
backpack showing how she is still on
that blue pill track for now remaining
in the simulation next clip just living
out their lives
oblivious
but this is the moment
for you to show us what is real
so jonathan graf plays neo's partner in
their company deus machina perhaps a
game developer or a film production
company some kind of pop culture
producer company name is named after
deus ex machina which was the name of
the central interface in machine city in
revolutions so the fact that neo is now
working for this shows how the machines
are really just rubbing it in his face
of course deus ex machina classically is
the greek term for god from the machine
in which in greek plays mortal
characters were rescued by gods from
above lowered in by crane and now in our
lexicon is a storytelling term for third
act divine intervention which in the
matrix revolutions that literally was
gross characters reciting the agent
smith monologue from the 1999 film that
i forced the poor classmates in my
freshman year drama club class to listen
to me recite doing my best to go weeping
impression but i gotta give groff credit
he really nails ego weaving's
enunciation of the word oblivious
oblivious oblivious but interesting to
note that nia was not present for this
monologue in the 99 film morpheus was
the audience so really this shows us how
this is just a script that the
simulation is recycling in a new program
one that looks like jonathan groff and
neo just thinks his partner is quoting a
line from a movie neo then remembers
smith melting his mouth shut and he sees
groff's mouth melting shut the same way
then morpheus and jessica henwick's
character bugs actually show the red
pill blue pill scene from the 1999 film
on a stage with that scene same two
plush red chairs and a mirror now keanu
reeves neo is on screen for this
screening i'm thinking either the
character of neo in the world of this
film was recast the way trinity seems to
have been recast and neo is only now for
the first time realizing he was actually
the original star of this story not just
fan casting himself in his dreams or
alternatively neo in a simulation could
actually be a famous movie star the way
cipher wanted to be a movie star upon
his reinsertion and the way keanu reeves
i assume probably thinks he's actually
in a matrix now notice a tear severs the
screen right between the red and blue
pills creating an entrance a door that
neo has to walk through making this
illusion of this fictional movie broken
as neo must re-enter his past also with
all the recurring neo-christ imagery of
this series you could see this as the
veil that tore the moment of the
crucifixion but i love that clever
framing here with the red pill over
morpheus head as we see him repeatedly
offering the red pill and wearing red
clothes whereas the blue pill is over
bugs who has blue hair moving on
[Music]
i remember this
okay on the far left of frame morpheus
and bugs push neo through a doorway and
you can see it looks like they're on the
bullet train that zips past mount fuji
but then on the right side of this
barrier his hands burst out of the red
lit gestation pod fluid then someone i
assume groth based on the later shot of
him with a gun in the office points a
gun at neo as sprinklers are raining
down this isn't any gun though this is
the desert eagle mark 19 pistol famously
this sidearm used by the agents in the
matrix films and then neo finds himself
back in the white construct and he
touches the back of his head the same
gesture that he does when entering the
construct for the first time in the 99
film to feel for his plug he realizes
that his hair is back i like how the
light goes from super oversaturated to
sharper contrast on keanu's face as
neo's memory returns to him next clip
and yet it's obviously all wrong
maybe this isn't the story we think it
is
they taught you good
made you believe their world was all you
deserved so bugs recognizes deja vu of
course the term in the matrix for a
repetitive glitch when the machine
sloppily changed something in the
simulation code taking the form of the
black cat that we also will see in this
movie in a therapist office but bug says
that the deja vu is all wrong meaning
that the deja vu wasn't an accidental
side effect but perhaps the base concept
that this entire simulation is based
upon like rather than changing something
and hoping they don't notice now the
simulation is overwhelming neo with deja
vu after deja vu so that he thinks his
constant vague familiarity is something
just wrong with his mind that he must
medicate and never ever see it as a
glitch in the matrix but just accepts
the reality that is presented to him
you'll notice behind bugs is tobian when
marie's character he's got tech over his
eye i actually think this might be the
character who has the machine arm that
we see later in the trailer maybe this
cruise operator just an interesting
reflection of how both humanity and the
machines are in a way dependent on each
other then a shot of someone alone on a
rooftop flaming helicopter wreckage
there the editing makes it seem like
it's neo but actually that shot of him
looking downward is really from the deck
party where he steps off the ledge this
lone figure is actually trinity because
she later tells neo this is where her
dream ends so she's probably perceiving
this all as a dream and notice the
reigning code on nearby salesforce tower
and the other skyscrapers trinity is
seeing the matrix for what it really is
remember neo alone was not the cycle
breaking anomaly his connection with and
love for trinity was really the key
component that changed everything moving
on
at some part of you knew that was a lie
some part of you remembered what was
real
it's so easy to forget how much noise
the matrix pumps into your head
something else makes the same kind of
noise
so neo steps off the ledge at this deck
party as the party-goers are begging him
to come back a bit extra i must say
suggesting to me that this could be a
dream or maybe they're just parts of the
simulation trying to keep him on track
and that could be what forces him into
therapy but the party may be what
triggered neo here red versus blue decor
on the tablecloths and chairs notice the
caterers are actually dressed like neo
from reloaded and on that screen it's
neo and agent smith's subway fight from
the 1999 film and there's also the
window washer carriage on the side of
the building that was morpheus's
instructed escape path before neo lost
his nerve i know i know you stare at the
stuff long enough and your eyes start to
feel like they're about to just drop out
of your head and roll down a drain
somewhere where pennywise can get them
and if you're like me and you spend a
lot of days staring intently at screens
like this you might notice some sore
eyes and problems sleeping and not just
because of sewer clowns well blue light
damages our eyes and leads to digital
eye strain symptoms of digital eye
strain include blurred vision headaches
dry watery eyes for some folks this can
even affect your energy level well blue
blocks was created to fix this problem
and block out the blue light with high
quality lenses thanks to blue blocks for
sponsoring this video blue blocks are
evidence-backed and made under optics
laboratory conditions in australia when
i'm spending time in fluorescent
lighting staring at screens these
glasses are a huge help they have over
40 styles of frames and come in
prescription non-prescription and
readers blue box also has other amazing
products such as low blue light bulbs
red light therapy devices and 100
blackout sleep masks they ship worldwide
in rapid time and make returns and
exchanges easy so go to blueblocks.com
new rockstars and use coupon code new
rockstars to save 20
that's blueblox.com b-l-u-b-l-o-x
dot com slash new rockstars and use code
new rockstars to save 20
then we hear the voice of naobi
explaining how the matrix pumps noise
into their heads which feels like a
commentary on consumerism
[Music]
and how in today's day and age wars are
waged over social media lana wakowski's
whole goal in the 1999 film was supposed
to reflect how digital technology
changed society their goal now is to
reflect how social media technology has
eroded our humanity on to the next bit
war
so here we see niobe returning jada
pinkett smith is playing a super
weathered version of herself scars
cataract on one eye meanwhile neo still
has that forever young keanu look young
dumb and full of
i think this is because neo's body was
restored rebooted kept fresh and clean
in that nutrient-rich pod whereas naomi
aged normally in the poor conditions of
zion just an interesting reflection of
how the machines have really done a
number to extend human lifespans not
really for the humans though just to
keep those batteries plugged in as long
as they can you'll notice on the back of
his shaped head neo has that same head
jack that he had in the previous films
but now an additional jack has been
installed on the back of his neck the
top of his final column actually that
later shot of trinity in her pod shows
that particular jack receives a tube
with glowing blue lights that could be
how the machines blue pill second-hand
humans that have been re-plugged back
into the matrix an additional layer of
security to keep them super plugged in
kind of like the ground wire of a wall
outlet it sounds like lawrence fishburne
morpheus is not going to be in this
movie other than the archive footage
like hugo weaving will appear in it but
yaya abdulmatine the second is playing
morpheus in this movie we just don't
know how yet he might be a bodyless
morpheus program a ghost in the machine
with a certain protocol he could also be
an avatar of morpheus younger self used
by another on the outside maybe older
morpheus or maybe older morpheus is dead
and niobe is using this as an avatar but
then we see an insane war on the surface
world between the machine harvesters it
looks like in these other ships this
could be a machine civil war machine
versus machine maybe these ships are
human operated but you do see more blue
versus red imagery the floating ships
fire blue blasts the harvesters fire
back at them red ones moving on
the most important choice in neil's life
it's not his demand
okay so jonathan groff's character again
syncs with agent smith identifying neo
as mr anderson which in the matrix films
was intended to be smith's way of
triggering neo by deliberately
misidentifying him with his simulation
label the frame backdrops red on graf
and then blue on the archive footage of
weaving from the revolution's final
battle which actually has been recolored
from its original green tint to blue
which you can definitely see in
weaving's blue eyes now really poppy in
here priyanka chopra appears as a grown
up sati from revolutions who i am
assuming will be an oracle type figure
she wore red framed glasses in the house
of nanking in the first trailer now
bathed in red light and she says the
choice is not neos to make which if you
think about it technically was true from
the first matrix film really it was
trinity's choice to kiss him back to
life which in that moment was a gender
reversal of that classic fairy tale
trope neo and graf's character restaged
the brawl in the dusty setting evoking
agent smith subway fight and then as
trinity leans forward in her pod the
editing sinks her movement into a kiss
with neo on the rooftop onto the next
clip
my turn to believe in her
[Music]
part of me feels like i have been
waiting my whole life for you
[Applause]
okay another echo of the 1999 film
bullet casings raining down upon us from
a helicopter overhead but here the
helicopter is firing at neo and trinity
leading to the endpoint of trinity's
dream then bugs it looks like descends
that light up sign shattering the bulbs
and the sparks on her way down but this
street is the same one that nia walks
down in his dream the frame within a
frame covered in green code and the way
that the surfaces of that street
suddenly change from smooth to bumpy is
also the case in this shot you can see
how the cobblestone changes abruptly
into smooth brick just a bizarre set
design element that definitely feels
like a kind of matrix glitch then this
shot that i love we've seen before where
trinity screams with alternate selves
blasting out of her all of these
actually appear to be played by
different women one looks like jessica
henwick making me wonder if bugs herself
could be another trinity analog program
in this new reboot and another kind of
looks like christina ricci who is going
to be playing some unknown character in
this film maybe an alternate version of
trinity as trinity tells neo it feels
like she's been waiting her whole life
for him look at the background it looks
like they're seated at a table in that
simulate coffee shop while swat officers
and an agent are just standing
menacingly behind them waiting for them
to finish but as you keep watching
there's some more context to this scene
i'll get to after the next clip if you
want to see twitter again
another shot of this coffee shop battle
as all those swat agents and fbi guys
get blown back from neo's table look
closely in the background there's not
only a few agents one of them actually
looks like jonathan groff neil patrick
harris's character is seated at the
table behind him so as i've suspected
that blue coated therapist could
actually be a representative of the
simulation perhaps the new architect but
there is something about neo and trinity
joining hands that gives them this power
up and notice how they are always
physically touching as they flee from
the police as they swerve on that
motorcycle through the green eyed drones
and then on the rooftop all of this
seems to have started from that one
chance handshake in that exchange in the
coffee shop that we saw in the first
trailer everything was going fine in the
new simulation until they just happened
to touch hands moving on
my dream ended here
so trinity describes that dream we were
talking about and neo again takes her
hand in the sunny location in the deja
vu trailer this ends with trinity
melting down in a green coat more red
versus blue imagery trinity opening her
eyes in the red pod cut to neo leaving
the matrix in this blue room back to
trinity's hand reaching out in the red
and then we stay on this epic shot of
neo and trinity jumping off the ledge
the leap of faith agonizing silence
staying on the shot way longer than
trailers normally stay on any one shot
and then we cut back to trinity in her
pod as it looks like some snaky wires
are undulating around her body grooves
notice that her pod appears to be alone
facing leftward and in the first trailer
there's a massive room with just two
pods facing each other i'm guessing
these are neo and trinity's pods with
machines sequestering these two with
extra security to make it impossible for
human rebels to unplug them that would
trap them in this seventh simulation as
prisoners of war in this ongoing machine
human conflict
and we end with neo fighting groff's
character calling back his big line from
the 99 film i still know kung fu it's a
little on the nose the kind of hollywood
sequel line that matrix resurrection
seems to be otherwise deconstructing so
i think neo might be saying this with a
kind of wink a guy who is fully aware of
what kind of reboot simulation he is in
and know that it is part of his code to
be young dumb and fully so i intend to
be doing a full analysis of matrix
resurrections after it comes out but if
i can't see it early i'm not going to
spend my christmas doing this i'm sorry
i need to recharge sometimes so if that
is the case our breakdown may be coming
out on the channel just a little bit
later like after the new year but when
you do see it i'm gonna go crazy on this
film i can't wait for it so to support
our channel check out our great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow the new rockstar subscribe to
director some more analysis of
everything you love thank you for
watching bye
[Music]
you